hello everyone thank you for joining in
and also uh hello to our future viewers
that might see this presentation
uh I'm Johan and now I'm gonna tell you
a little bit about the data frame
Library decks and how you can use it for
building a fast and responsive data apps
this whole introduction I work as a data
scientist in the company called tickets
and I'm drawing today also by Martin
gretels who is the primary author of Dex
and he will be lurking and monitoring
the chat in Discord and on YouTube so if
you have any questions throughout this
presentation please feel free to write
it there and I think you'll do his best
to answer it
so let's jump into it what is Vex
is a data frame Library a high
performance one in Python when you think
of a data frame Library most of you will
immediately think of pandas and with
good reason pandas has been probably one
of the main reasons why python is the
data science language today
however we'll know about the kind of
limitations that pandas has in terms of
performance and working with larger data
sets and this is where Vex comes in
so this promises to work with later Raj
data sets on a single machine and that's
the goal of the project the idea is to
work with as large data sets as you can
fit on a single hard drive and fairly
interactively so that means a single
node processing like a machine like your
laptop or a single machine in the cloud
should be able to work with around a
billion points in a reasonable time of a
couple of seconds per typical operation
the API is similar to bangas although
Vex itself does not build up on pandas
if unlike other project this doesn't
want to extend or make it scale it's a
fully new implementation but we're
trying to keep close to the pandas API
as much as possible
hopefully to limit the learning curve of
course it's free and open source you can
easily try it and install it here pip
and quota
so how does it work how does it how is
it so fast it's a combination of fast
efficient C plus algorithms mainly
developed by Martin
and streaming data for Concepts so text
is optimized for reading data from disk
and Vex actually streams the data from
disk and applies this efficient
algorithms to do fast aggregations and
processing this is greatly held by
storing the data in a Smart Way usually
this involves memory mappable column
storage like hdfi files or or material
that can be easily memory mapped of
course if you have parquet or CSV files
that will work as well
in addition to this we have what we call
an expression system that as you work
with Vex behind the scene it computes or
creates a rather like Amina like a
Computing graph which
uh when executed allows for better
computational efficiency and memory
efficiency
X is lazy so it will only evaluate
expressions when absolutely necessary
and last but not least many operations
can be additionally sped up by using
just in time compilation
and the interesting thing here is that
we also support gpus so it could be a
bit of a gimmick at some point but we do
support both Nvidia gpus and
and gpus on Apple machines
under the hood the X has two main
components so the coral X is written in
C plus plus as I said earlier various
efficient algorithms mainly developed by
Martin then do the the corporations such
as Group by statistics computation so
various types or Computing join
Computing hashmaps we're doing joints
and so on
however we also rely on the Apache error
project for additional functionality
and on my screen you can see some
examples this is by no means an
exhaustive list but just to give you a
sense of
where things are coming from we also
tried to contribute to the budget
project whenever possible like in the
past
the the string operations that are now
part of uh of the Aero project were
developed by Martin for the purpose of X
and then we work together and now
they're part of the Apache air project
so this is a little intro of how things
work I'm going to demo this in a second
but just to give you a sense of how
things work
uh in Vex which is a bit different to
pandas a bit of a paradigm shift
so when we work with the file let's say
we want to open it and the file is
already now friendly hdfi file format
what happens is that next says okay I'm
going to do nothing but I know what the
metadata looks like and by that I mean I
know that this file has two columns and
I know where they are on this because I
can memory map it
now let's say I want to create a second
data frame that is a just a filter of
the first one
what happens is that the data is not
being copied and it's actually immutable
and it keeps on living in a disk and
nothing has happened in the data but now
we have this dictionary essentially a
dictionary we call the state that embeds
all the operations we've done to reach
this data frame too so in this case we
want a few filter data frame one the
data isn't changed but we say okay
whenever we need to work with data frame
to we need to execute this condition
this will
the same thing happens when we want to
add a new column let's say we want to
add a new column Z we still Unchained we
don't change anything to do with the
original data we don't create a new data
in memory but we add an additional
field to our main dictionary that says
okay now there is such a column called Z
that exists and to do it to work with it
you need to evaluate this expression and
this is done on the Fly
this enables all kind of cool
applications most notably in the field
of machine learning where as a byproduct
of this workflow one can get automatic
pipelines of basically any kind of
pre-processing or building their own
models but this is perhaps a talk for
another day
today I'm going to focus on the various
performance optimizations you can you
can do with the X mainly as a backend
for uh for a data
so what does a modern data type need in
fact today data is always kind of
growing sometimes that's good sometimes
annoying but we need to be ready for it
of course we want our data helped to be
fast and responsive regardless of how
big the data size is
with databs the operations are often
repetitive we tend to start on the same
home page and maybe the first few clicks
are kind of the same and we do want to
have the flexibility of computing
various statistics custom visualizations
and maybe even interface to various ml
models something that many of the shell
bi tools cannot always do
and this can help here
um mainly because of its high
performance the C plus plus and Pyro
back ends that we talked about
and many of these additional steps that
I'm going to demo to you in a second
that really help in creating uh data
apps
so bear with me let me
[Music]
to
a jupyter notebook
I hope you can see this
and that it's the right amount of
font size perhaps I can
increase it if necessary
so for this demo I'm going to use a
portion of the GL data set just to
introduce it very quickly the gdelt is a
project that scans and monitors the
world for any published article and
basically creates metadata about the
part the published articles it's a very
fascinating project I recommend you
check it out also the data set is very
fun to work with especially for testing
uh sort of Big Data tools so let's go
into it
let's import the usual libraries
and our snapshot of this data set that I
have locally on disk is around 350
gigabytes so it's
it's kind of large enough to be
considered a problem under normal
circumstances
this file with vex
is quite quite simple you see opening it
opening is almost immediate because we
don't really touch the data this is just
knows where the relevant columns are in
disk and gets to read some metadata
about it like the number of rows a
number of columns
we can inspect the file and this is also
quite fast we can do it multiple times
because we're not really reading the
entire data set but this is essentially
a hidden tail operation and because the
data is never remapped we can
immediately access the top and the
bottom five rows so we can easily
inspect inspect this this file
if you want to filter or make copies
it's essentially the same procedure so
let's say we care only about the subset
of the columns in this
in this file again we don't really make
a copy that just accesses the rows that
it needs and the columns that it needs
in this case
accessing a single column is just as
easy we get a simple preview of the top
and bottom five rows and it doesn't
really matter how big how big this this
number is how many rows you have you
always access the first and last the
fibros it will always be fast
so in this case for this data set this
average tone it's something like a
sentiment of the article because the
Digital Data reads it and processes and
gets let us know what is most important
about an article
and we have another column actor type
where actors in this data set are
something like entities
about
that are related to the article and this
have various codes
so going back to Vex we can do various
operations for example if we have a
division between two numerical columns
again we don't have to stream over the
entire data set in this case we just get
a preview of what would happen if we do
it the first and the last rows it's very
fast
we can then take this expression and
assign it to a data frame
and then this expression like I showed
in the intro before will be
acting as a well is a normal column just
the same as the other ones even though
it's not doesn't live in memory but this
data frame knows that it exists and when
it's asked for it it will be evaluated
from the fly that makes uh that saves a
lot of memory especially in machine
learning procedure when you have to
create a lot of features
where things do get eagerly executed is
when you need to compute aggregations or
you need to fundamentally change the
structure nature of the data frame such
as Computing a mean so now instead of
just doing
a preview the X will actually compute
the mean and you see that it's for like
600 million rows it's quite fast
it's less than a second and this is
where actually where Vex excels
Computing all kind of Statistics in
numerical columns for example we can do
a count of a column we can compute the
mean now we're completing the mean over
two two columns in the same password for
the data it's a nice nice optimization
we can also do this Statistics like
current and mean and so on along the
axis
and being on an access which essentially
gives us a histogram
and yeah this is maybe not so pretty but
but you get the idea and Vex also offers
um a wrapper so you can get a nice
convenience method that you get a nice
histogram function but basically this is
what we're doing
it's not just about American values we
can also do the usual type of
aggregations and the value accounts
method is probably my favorite method uh
in data science no matter which data
frame Library I'm using so index has a
bit of a special treatment some extra
optimization behind the scene to make it
faster
and the usual for example working within
unique values and group by and you see
we started with a 300 gigabyte
data file we're doing all these kind of
operations on a single machine you kind
of forget that you're working with sort
of large data or kind of sort of big
data but everything is kind of smooth
and here just uh I want to take a second
to
mention another one of my favorite
features of X so this is a Standard
Group by operation we're grouping by two
columns and we're Computing the mean and
the standard deviation of this one
column very similar to the pandas
notation
however here I do something more special
for example I do want to calculate the
mean of this particular column but
according to some additional filter
and next we can do this by passing the
dedicated aggregation function I can
specify what aggravation what I do I
want to do but also if I want that
aggregation to specif to obey a certain
condition
and this is quite convenient you can
imagine how would you do this in SQL or
other data from libraries you probably
have to do two group bias and enjoy them
it's a bit more cumbersome so index we
do care about speed but also about
convenience
so that's a very quick and hopefully not
too dirty introduction to the main
features of this and now let's apply
them to create a nice nice hopefully
fast
application
so here are some definitions of the
actor codes of this in this video data
set I took this from the documentation
to check it out it's really really
fascinating data set
and I proceed to create a simple filter
function that will take in a list of
codes and it will basically filter out
every other entry that doesn't have that
code so yeah
the syntax here is exactly the same as
in pandas
however do know that we are doing six
filtering operations here over this weak
data set and optionally maybe additional
two operations if a user specifies like
a limit on on the Year this is all
calculated basically we don't need to
use it yet so you get to see a preview
immediately
so let's filter our data frame with the
filter that we specified above this is
too lazy nothing has happened
and at this point we want to start like
maybe optimizing our process a little
bit so the first thing let's say we want
to compute a series of operations it
doesn't really matter what they are you
can you can look at them in your own
time later but essentially we're doing
things like we're counting we're
Computing some means some average of
columns and group by and so on so some
things are will be first and some things
will be slow by wrapping this whole
workflow in a context manager
index with this progress through context
manager and I execute this operation you
get to see uh
tree of timings so you can really drill
down into what makes your process or
application slow or fast so for example
in this line over here we're calculating
the mean of these two columns
here we can see that here we're
calculating the mean
but to calculate the mean of this column
we need to calculate the sum of it and
also count how many items are in it so
we get to see exact timings of each
operation so then we can really drill
down into whatever process we're doing
that may be slow maybe there is a way to
improve it or maybe
maybe replace it with some more
efficient process
and not only that next to the timings
here in square brackets we do get to see
numbers
and this numbers indicate how many times
over the course of this progress three
Vex had to read data from disk from
scratch so how many passes over the data
you have to go so in this case for
example to calculate the count at the
start this is one possible data then to
calculate the means of these columns
it's another part of the data then to
calculate the sum it's a third pass and
so on
uh so this also gives you an additional
insight about the performance of your
application or your pipeline or
transformation whatever you may be
working on
and yeah this is a summary of of what we
calculated again so you may be asking
like wow this uh it's quite fast but you
do have to read the data from this quite
a lot can we do better like yeah sure we
can do better and that's the next topic
delay computations
and this is Maybe
something that's slightly different from
other lazy libraries so for example
things like Das will always be lazy they
will always kind of defer the
computation to a user exclusive this
says okay now I want to know my result
index we've taken a little bit of a
different approach where we've put an
emphasis on the exploration so more from
a data science perspective you get a new
data set you need to do a lot of trial
on your filter the data look into it and
you want to have immediate immediate
answers to your group by segregations
filters and so on however when you're
more safe from the process like I'm set
on this demo you can still optimize
things further for example every
operation that would be otherwise
computed eagerly we can pass this delay
true argument so for example when we do
a count when we calculate the mean sum
group buys and so on we can pass this
delay argument that says okay we're not
done specifying the list of operations
that we want to do so wait until
the code meets this execute statement at
this point all these operations will be
executed in parallel and Vex will try to
find the optimal computational graph and
how to
so now if I execute this code cell
you see that all these operations
that we where we use the delay true
argument were done in a single Passover
data and if we compare the timings it's
a bit a bit more efficient
another interesting optimization that
you can do is turn on caching so the X
implements quite a granular cache
mechanism
and it supports both
disk and RAM caching
so we can turn it on globally like this
check it it's on
and now we have the very same code
nothing has changed we run it once
we can scroll down here nothing has
changed because now it's the first time
that we run this uh this uh set of
operations after return on caching but
if we run it again
we see that the results are basically
taken from Cache and the fun thing or
the good thing here is that the cache is
done on the kind of small level of each
of these operations so for example even
though we never explicitly wanted to
know the sum of this particular column
if in the future we want to
do some other computation that requires
the sum of this column it will be used
from Cache directly so let's uh and
that's kind of the power of doing this
on a very granular level that that's
that X provides
so at this point we can take the outputs
of uh of our function and visualize them
so first we know what we want to do
let's say we're set on Computing some
high level statistics like the counts
means and group by aggregations we can
rub them into a function we don't over
give the progress bar because we're
we're accepted with the performance we
can test it out given a filter give me
the results of my workflow and then we
can wrap it up in a some sort of
visualization here I use some closely
code to create a world map you'll see it
in a second and then you can display
this uh this visualization sources
visualizations with your favorite
desperate making library or web app
making Library here I'm using Solara
it's a nice tool you should check it out
because it allows me to do this demo in
the jupyter notebooks I don't have to
switch context too much
um
also works outside and Jupiter and the
app that we built will look like this
this is the output of all the group by
aggregations and this is the output of
the individual cameras so for example
now I can select additional after code
and the computations will be triggered
you will see the new definition the map
has been updated and because we have
caching on if now we go back to the
original state things will be
immediately uh immediately
we can immediately go back
so that's it for the demo let me go back
to the slides in a second
so far a bit more involved examples you
can check out these two examples that we
have made with streamlit and dash these
are Live Links streamlined.vex.io or
dash.x.io the streamlined version is
essentially a slightly more
sophisticated
uh version of the web app I just showed
you in Jupiter and on the right we have
an example with Dash with ploty Dash
that well you can also check out
in your own time also the implementation
of both of these dashboards is available
on our GitHub account also please feel
free to to have a look and see how we
implemented this in these things
and um it's I think it's important to
know that Vex is using production we
have worked together with plotly so it's
quite tested under flask and fast API
and it's uh it has nice features for uh
well such as all the memory mapping
processes where you can share data
between different systems and also the
integration caching
and some companies are that we know of
at least do use decks in production for
important uh for important applications
most notably Galileo I think has based a
lot of their
processing data processing service based
on decks so if you do want to learn more
about that please get in touch with us
or with them for that matter
and finally we do run a consultancy
around Vex that's how we are able to
continue development and maintaining the
project so you do get in touch if you're
interested or in general you can get in
touch with us through the main channels
GitHub
Twitter and so on please get in touch if
you have any questions or issues or
ideas or feature requests we love to
hear from from everyone and hopefully we
can do more work together to
help our on our own data Journeys so
thanks
thank you very much
Jovan for the amazing session and I can
see there are a few questions on the
comment section
uh so one of the users is asking
how they can assess the notebook
you've just shared so
after this talk I'm going to put all the
materials or the notebook and the slides
on a GitHub repo called Vex stocks and
we'll share the link in Discord as soon
as that's live I just wanted to have the
real version of The Notebook from the
talk to being GitHub that's why I didn't
post it before
all right all right thank you very much
and
um the next question
from Mikhail what works performance for
small data sets comparable to Panda slow
fast faster
so the question is how small if they're
very small like 1000 rows or ten
thousand rows
it will be
it will depend a bit so if you have a
super powerful machines with many cores
there will be some overhead index due to
parallelization so it could end up being
slower
but if you I think surpass
few hundred thousand rows it will be the
same
all right thank you very much and then
the last question
from Joseph
so with cashing is there time period
before vax reruns an operation to get a
metrics like sums
Etc to keep current the value current
yes good question so there are several
strategies of how
um of how the caching works so you can
limit memory I think you can also limit
by time
this does deserve a better
documentation from our side but there
are several strategy on how you can keep
the how long you keep the cash when you
decide to recompute maybe I can get back
to this uh in Discord and maybe Martin
has already answered this in this card
but yeah there are several strategy to
do this
all right
um I think Martin also put on the
the charts that uh no need to use lru
cash as well